[Music]
while they're not as good as an actual
surround sound system gaming headsets
have come a long way besides maybe you
don't have the room or money for a 5.1
setup in your room or apartment I've
been gaming with surround sound
headphones for almost a decade now and I
think if you're serious about having a
respectable audio experience one of
these high-end gaming headsets is for
you this is only a small sample of
what's out there but hopefully it gives
you an idea of how to spot quality when
shopping for a new surround sound gaming
headset ok let's start with turtle beach
turtle beach offers an endless amount of
options for Xbox and Playstation
platforms and the most expensive model
is the 800 line of headsets the elite
eight hundred and elite 800 x offer
surround sound and noise cancelling
features for ps4 and Xbox one
respectively and they charge in these
really convenient cradles plus they have
optical ins and outs on the base so you
don't lose sound on your regular AV
receiver setup but and this is a big but
they both go for three hundred dollars
that premium price is mostly for the
extra features and solid build quality
but actually they started to annoy me
after I wore them for an extended gaming
session fortunately for ps4 owners I can
recommend the stealth 500p which is only
a hundred dollars it removes the
charging cradle Bluetooth and noise
cancelling features but it retains what
you want that's the surround sound and
chat albeit it's got this really super
awkward USB dongle set up for Xbox one
the 500x is a cheaper alternative but
it's still pricey at two hundred and
thirty dollars gone also are the cradle
bluetooth and noise cancelling features
but at least you can chat wirelessly on
xbox one and game with surround sound
okay let's move over to Astro gaming the
new tournament ready a 40 s are super
comfortable lightweight and come in two
varieties one for xbox one and one for
ps4 and you can use them both with a pc
connection as well because they're wired
you get minimal sound delay like you
might encounter with other wireless
connections the
a 40 TRS come with a mix and pro that
lets you mix game and chat audio in real
time now there's two versions available
they're both for two hundred and fifty
dollars the white version is for Xbox
one that allows for chatting without a
clunky adapter the mixamp can also
connect to a pc where you can access eq
management software called command
center it lets you customize the
experience when you plug in the mixamp
to a pc all you do is download the
software and you can do a ton of
customization all these settings are
available and then you load that into
the mixamp now if you're at which gamer
and need to have a precise gaming no
delay experience the a 40 s are really
the headset to be Astro also offers the
ability to customize the headphones and
they sell a mod kit for the 840 s
that'll actually let you swap out the
earcups the headband and a boom mic and
those mod kits go for sixty dollars
finally I want to take a look at a
headset that's specifically designed for
PC I absolutely love the logitech g930 3
Artemis spectrum wireless surround
headset it goes for about two hundred
dollars but it provides the best
surround sound for PC that I've tested
the G 933 lets you customize the RGB LED
light that shines when it's turned on
and the logitech gaming software allows
you to assign commands for the buttons
that are on the headset itself you can
also customize EQ settings as well now
for wireless pc gaming it's all you need
but for fifty dollars cheaper the g 633
does the same exact thing but with a
wired connection now there are plenty of
solid products that I didn't get to
include here steelseries makes a great
headset in the Siberia line and Sony
even makes proprietary headsets for the
ps4 that are actually pretty solid as
well hopefully you've gotten a good
taste of what to look out for in the
high-end surround sound gaming landscape
be sure to reach out to me on twitter if
you've got more questions about anything
you've seen here i'm jeff bakalar
foreseen it thanks so much for watching
[Music]